tasks a is impossible for computational
model B so we're gonna do this by
finding a results showing how algorithm
design implies laura balanced
okay so we'll say yes or some a prime
and B Prime
if task a prime is possible for
computational model B prime then task a
is impossible computational model B ok
and then we're going to use results from
album design to show that task a prime
is possible for computation well B so
the idea is just to reduce it to some
kind of standard album design problem
where we were just trying to prove an
upper bound you know I will be prime we
can solve a certain task a prime well
and so the whole game is you know where
do we start with such things like with
like how can we show that when something
is possible another thing is impossible
again it goes back to two meta
computation so I want to relate a prime
in in model B in a certain sense so I'm
going to define task a prime which I am
solving to be about analyzing model B so
you're given some instance of model B
and you're gonna say something
interesting and that's task a prime it's
very high level but that's the that's
all that's all essentially what's
happening and then between task a and B
Prime
we're going to define task a to be in
terms of ball B prime somehow it's
something that's maybe defines respect
to B prime in a particular way so that
whenever I'm able in B prime to solve
this task a prime I can say something
about like limitations in one will be so
again this is a really high level thing
but but ok so we can make it a little
more concrete based on what we've said
so far
I had some other okay had some other
slide okay fine so here's a very simple
example from complexity theory of how
album design can imply lower bounce so I
mean there are lots of such examples so
one is that if P space equals
exponential time then P times R in from
P space so just recall P space is the
class of problem solve with a fishing
rod of space final amount of space B
time polynomial time and now so these
things are really easy and you can
easily kind of combine these things from
known look well we're bound so by the
time hierarchy theorem was sort of a
very standard result upon a long time is
doing from exponential time and so you
can easily prove the contrapositive so
these results you know there's many such
things that you can say in but they're
not very useful for us because they
could sort of say something like if pigs
can fly then pigs can oink okay so it's
like if it's totally unexpected insane
breakthrough happens then something
totally expected that we believe to be
true happens so yeah we want
implications like I mean we want
implications with plausible algorithm
design hypotheses so things that you
know don't say that like everything
exponential time can be done with a
fishing amount of space and like that
like something with plausible album
design hypotheses that you know things
that we might prove true in our
lifetimes and get some maybe lower bound
we expect that just seemed very hard
without it would seem you seem like much
more intractable than the algorithm
design problem this is so maybe my long
lines of if if cows can move in pigs
cannot Wayne can you oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah I mean the thing is it's like
things that we expect to be true but we
just cannot proof right there's a lot
there's the complexity theory is just
absolutely chock-full of such statements
propositions right
yeah we want the proof yeah we I mean
you know like I'll maybe you know if you
really formalize it out maybe it's not
maybe it's hard to prove because no one
plus one equals two Principia okay
so the big idea is that interesting
circuit analysis algorithms can tell us
about limitations of circuits in
modeling algorithms okay I'll say more
detail about this but that's the big
idea at a high level so the idea is if
we have some Turing machine type model
so I mean it could be anything
equivalent to your Turing machine it's
performing some non-trivial circuit
analysis okay like it says for all
circuits that I'm giving to you encoded
on the tape encoded as input say in bits
I can tell you whether or not this
circuit is satisfiable so whether it has
an input which makes it print 1 and
somehow I'm beating brute force so I'm
doing better somehow then if I only had
black box access to that thing so given
the description of the circuit well how
all the gates connect together and all
that somehow I'm doing better than if I
could only query inputs and see outputs
okay so by having you know so there
exists in a for all in this way we want
to say there exists interesting
functions define with respect to Turing
machines okay maybe in a similar way
such that for all finite slices of that
function f they cannot be computed by
all circuits of the particular kind we
have analyzed okay so we want to prove
circuit lower bounds so we want to prove
that there are some interesting
functions which do not have efficient
circuits for all finite slices of this
one so when I restrict the function to a
particular length of inputs and the the
Ru underlying this kind of connection is
that when I can do this non-trivial
circuit analysis I'm somehow showing
that circuits are different from black
boxes in some fundamental way so if if
only has a black box to try to solve sat
with then in the worst case I'm just
going to have to try all the possible
inputs the circuit and see if I ever get
a one okay but if I can beat brute force
given the description somehow I am
showing circuits are not black boxes to
these kinds of algorithms
so whatever algorithms I'm getting with
this computational model here and so
using this so just showing that this
kind of non obfuscation type result is
possible we we wish to you know say this
is a limitation on circuits which we can
lift to actual a lower bound on
computing with those circuits and the
idea is that this is an inherently sort
of non relativizing approach so as a
saying the realization barrier is about
like when you stick black boxes in
everywhere as the argument still go
through and so they explicitly setting
up as I hypothesize that you know give
it a description you can do more the
description of a circuit you can do more
okay so so going back to our kind of
high-level blue blueprint our goal is to
show that algorithmic task a is
impossible for efficient circuits so
this is our model B so our model B will
be efficient circuits and we're going to
show how non-trivial analysis of
efficient circuits is possible with
algorithms and that's our model B prime
so sort of Turing machine type albums
and then we'll use this to show that
certain element tasks a defines respect
to this model B prime so just normal
algorithms is impossible for efficient
circuits so the game will be just
designing algorithms which will analyze
circuits given this input so that that's
that's what we're going to sort of
reduce our lower bound problem to so
things like given the description of a
circuit does it compute a trivial
function say they're all zeros function
always output zero are animals outputs
one or something like this okay
is it feasible to say what kind of a
non-trivial analysis we are seeking yeah
so in this lectures I'll talk about two
and they're based on the sap problems
one is essentially the sap problem the
fires respect to particular so your
classes and one is a much more relaxed
version this almost certainly solvable
in polynomial time he's essentially a
dear Animas ation question so that's
what I'll talk about here I mean there
are others like say based on learning
and basis like given the truth table of
a function say something about its
circuit complexity the circuit size
problem I won't talk about any of those
whose only have two hours but there
there are assert several such tasks that
people have shown imply lower bounds
just think of the circuit is a black
book that's true that is true yeah yeah
I mean yeah that does sort of run
counter to what I was just saying but
but certainly a non black box thing that
runs slightly faster than exhaustive
search would suffice
I mean it could boil down to sort of how
much better than exhaustive search can
you do
with the high-level view so now I'll
talk about albums versus boolean
circuits so I'm gonna sort of breeze
through this a bit it's you know it's
stuff that is seen in introductory
complexity courses but I just want to
review it for everybody so so we have
two models of computation one is the
usual Turing type model algorithms you
can take an arbitrary long inputs and
still solve the problem but it has
constant size descriptions okay so
something that goes from arbitrary bit
strings to a bit strings just think
about bit strings and like is the like
decision problems so yes or no answers
and we'll look at the boolean circuit
model wait and then when we usually
define this is the only take in fixed
length inputs so they're only computing
some finite function so from the point
of view of the algorithmic model just
with like a fixed length input this is
kind of trivial you can always hard code
such things into the description but
we'd like to say well what can what does
it mean for like circuits to be able to
solve this kind of decision problem
which can take arbitrary long inputs
there's an easy way to define such
things we just give you implementing
circuits so we define a circuit family
to be some infinite family of circuits
where the int circuit so every input
lint links in there's a C sub n that's
run on all inputs of LinkedIn so the
computational model is you sort of look
up in this infinite description your
input length where it is and then you
run it you know see 7,000 inputs of
length of thousand now given this kind
of definition that it's it's clear that
we can talk about circuit families
solving such decision problems okay and
we want to know sort of how large do
these circuits have to grow as a
function of the input length that
they're given so the the notion of
efficient computation here is ppalli
it's a set of decision problems so
taking arbitrary bit strings out putting
bits computable by a circuit family of
this kind so that the size of the in
circuit is bounded up from above by a
fixed polynomial so
occasions for all in the size of C sub n
is at most indicate right there's some
fixed polynomial bounding this thing as
the input links grow so each circuit is
small relative its number of inputs so
this circuit model has programs with
infinite length descriptions and so this
means that the standard methods and
computability theory that are used to to
say all kinds of nice statements are
basically powerless here because
essentially all of them use the fact
that you that your algorithm all has a
finite description so for example there
undecidable problems in p poly and it's
like really easy to construct things or
even like in subsets of people you say
linear size circuit family so they only
have order in size or even constant size
that are undecidable problems because of
this infinite length description you can
have encode like some undecidable thing
and infinitely alright so this makes it
very tricky to try to analyze the
circuit families in their power ok so
why study this kind of model I mean it's
it seems fairly impractical have an
infinite model well the idea is that at
any point in time you know in terms of
technological development you know there
is some length up to a certain length
that is relevant for us like the links
of the inputs that are relevant for us
and like what could we feasibly compute
with this kind of input length okay so
for one I mean one a mathematical level
circuits could be easier to analyze in
Turing machines just try to think of
like how you would say what the Turing
machines eventual behavior is gonna be
versus like just things computed of a
NAND or not gates they could be easier
in licenses one of the motivations are
studying circuit complexity or say
trying to prove lower bounds about
Turing machines using circuits the
second thing is that proving limitations
on ppalli would be some step towards a
non asymptotic complexity theory where
we're not talking about polynomials or
Exponential's just numbers sort of
concrete numerical limits on computing
so things of the form any logical
circuits solving most instances of my
thousand bit problem needs at least ten
to the hundred bit sieve
be described in some reasonable way okay
so the newer to tell you how the gates
connect and all that thing and so why
this is relevant is that well the
universe apparently stores less than 10
to the 80 bits this is the so-called
bekenstein bound so like to describe
like a program solving the problem say
1,000 bit instances I need something
larger than the size of the universe as
we know it and maybe you could have
average case such flow around this is
you could think about like well can we
like show that according to known
physics like this problem is just
literally not solvable like at all
nobody could imagine basing a
cryptography and such things
so meieran stockmeyer just to put a note
like they they did prove such lower
bounds in the 70s for problems that are
very hard like like high-end the so
called exponential hierarchy type heart
so for certain logic problems these
things are true but they're like the
extraordinarily hard problems but the
idea is that like you can only prove
such sorts of statements when you think
of the trade-off between the input size
and the size of the computation so if
you just talk about whether a Turing
machine is gonna solve a problem that
you don't really get to such a question
that's that's another reason to look at
circuit families so just to recall in
fact so most boolean functions require
huge circuits so it's by a simple
counting argument a random boolean
function neat circuits of size say at
least to the N divided by n and it's
known that this lower bound is actually
tight up to like say a low order terms
so you can get circuits of size to the N
divided by n for any function okay in
bits to a bit so but the question is can
we get explicit sort of non-random heart
function so Fung is that we would like
to compute can we show that they are
going to require exponential circuit
complexity so this leads is a question
sort of what uniform algorithms can be
simulating ppalli so in other words like
thing algorithm is defined by Turing
machines which of these can be some
million people
so could every problem solvable in
exponential time on a Turing machine be
simulated with only polynomial size
circuit families so I mean or
non-deterministic exponential times
where you have exponentially long
solutions verifiable exponential time
can they be simulated with small non
uniform class so how how strong does
computation get whenever I get to design
a separate circuit for each input length
so this is this is the the general
question look at and the key obstacles
that non-uniformity can be very powerful
like as I said that there are
undecidable problems that one can solve
in things like ppalli so so you know
proving that something can't be in
people is going to have to you know take
some some kind of interesting argument
that's outside of the realm of
computability theory okay so one
ridiculously open problem that I hope we
will make a little progress on the
semester is whether NX is in P poly so
this ask can all problems with
exponentially long answers check with
exponential time can they be solved with
polynomial size circuit family so just
because I give you a separate circuit
for each input length can you magically
sort of compress the computation down
from exponential to polynomial so we
call em P as Palo me along in answer is
terrible in polynomial time this is just
the exponential time version of this
thing I mean the it seems sort of
obviously know that like just because
you get this like separate circulation
but length there's nothing special about
particular input links and you know like
you Exponential's can't be made
polynomials magically so we believe
absolutely not but we don't know how to
prove it but I will talk about some ways
in which we might do that so it's
conjecture that NP is not in P poly ok
so now even like the Sat problem and
things like that or NP poly of course is
this is harder than proving P Michael NP
I mean sieve showing that you can't even
get some non-uniform version of
polynomial time for the SAP problem so I
mean the making progress on this is
probably you know outside the scope of
this mr. Li okay
I'm not gonna say it isn't but I said
probably okay I mean it's like you know
we can drink you know but but like this
kind of thing I believe is in striking
distance another thing that I think is
in striking distance is whether MP has
linear size circuits so this so size
order in the size estimate in general
just means that the inte circuit has
size at most s event so here it's like
saying that the in circuit has it size
at most a constant times n so they're
scaling just linearly with the input
length the best known is that the
circuit size when you have an or and not
gates is 5 n so the function even in
polynomial time doesn't have 5 inside
circuits and when you throw in parity
gates becomes 3.01
and and this point o 1/n was that it was
a real breakthrough that happened not so
long ago actually so what can we like
replace this kind of constant with
arbitrary constant this is something
that I think it may be attackable and
for reasons that I will explain their
questions finest approach the way we to
make progress it really is a non
uniformity because when you drop the
slash poly like these things follow from
time hierarchy theorems by like at least
the questions I've stated here right we
know that like N squared time can't be
simulated in linear time and things like
that so yeah the what makes the the
problems interesting it would make some
so annoying is this non-uniform aspect
there like the the simulator that I'm
trying to say can't work is some
infinite length description
so now I'll state a few theorems about
how circuit analysis albums can imply
lower bounds and then talk about details
so the first problem we'll look at is
the so called generalized circuit
satisfiability problem so we let C be
some class of boolean circuits they
could be boolean formula sort of tree
like circuits they could just be
arbitrary things connected however you
like
they could be C 3 CNF so ands of ORS are
the most three variables each like well
you know that this representation is
already difficult say for the Sat
problem but for any such Class C we can
define a C set problem which is just
given a circuit from this class with in
boolean inputs is there some input
assignment which makes the circuit
output one or does every assignment make
it up at zero is it computing sort of a
trivial all zeroes function so this is a
very simple problem from the point of
view of circuit analysis you just want
to know if it's computing a trivial
function or not but as we well know the
qu Claven theorem says that this thing
is MP complete for essentially all
interesting certain classes C so we are
not going to necessarily solve it in
polynomial time this equals NP but the
problem is solvable it's all by brute
force over all to the n inputs to the
problem and then evaluating each input
on the size of the circuit so this is
the size of sir ok and so while the
thing is np-complete we could still ask
can it be solved faster than trivial
brute force when I give you the
description of the circuit so if I just
gave you the circuit as a black box and
just said you can only probe inputs and
see the output
that would also take to the end time to
just try all the inputs and see the
possible outputs and see if you ever
printed it one so it's interesting
aspect whether we can even improve all
upon this running time and and but
before this research this was
area that people studied and they study
it for a particular smaller classes like
3 CS and so on another problem we'll
look at which looks a lot more tractable
is so-called gap circuit satisfiability
problem in here again we start with some
class of boolean circuit C and we're
asked given a circuit K from this class
and we're promised that this circuit is
either unsatisfiable so in other words
every input makes it print 0 ok or when
I pick a random input at least half of
them make it print 1 so so it's a huge
gap between the two cases
so I'm promised that like either
everything makes it print 0 or at least
half of them they get print 1 and I just
want to decide which of these two is the
case so this is a much simpler problem
it's easily solvable and randomized
paano time with high probability by just
taking random uniform random inputs
plugging them in and see if it ever
prints one and you will distinguish
between these two promises very you know
very quickly with high probability okay
in fact like it's known that in a
certain sense this is complete for say P
versus RP I mean it's really sort of so
got a promise RP complete but I won't go
into this notation the the thing to know
is that if if this problem solving all
the time then in fact a randomized
opponent all the time say one-sided
error is can be simulating deterministic
upon all the time so it's complete but
in a kind of different sense in the
sense that we expect so buggy theorists
expected the randomness can be removed
and another interesting point is that
work of here Shin Trevisan shows that
special cases of this problem is just in
polynomial time so for example for all
constants K the gap case at problem is
in poly no time either they're just ways
to solve it deterministically whereas
the 3sat problem
as we know already is infamously and be
complete probably not in pollen time so
here is a case where we have like
special cases that already seem fairly
expressive but we can show the Grampa a
little time so these are two kind of
problems we're gonna look at circuits
that in this seemingly much easier so so
now I'm going to describe some of the
connections that we that have been
proved between getting a faster CSAT
algorithm for various circuit glasses C
and circuit lower balance for that Class
C on the left hand side I'll be talking
about sort of upper bounds and the right
hand side I'll be talking about the
implied lower bounds
so if we get deterministic algorithms
for let's say the circuits at problem
okay and here I'm going to be looking at
for all constants K I am given an n to
the K gate circuit let's say each gate
has spent in two so Ana nor with not
gates with fan and two in inputs
exhaustive search would take about to
the end times into the K if I can solve
it in to the N divided by into the 10
your 10 is sufficiently large constant
depending on the combination of model if
I can solve it faster than exhaustive
search just sort of slightly faster this
would already imply that NX is not in P
poly ok so just some mild looking
improvements over exhaustive search
things are just saving by a polynomial
amount on polynomial side circuits would
imply this sort of embarrassing but
major open question circumplex II and
this connection is sort of preserved by
the circuit class in many ways so for
example if I maybe can't solve the
circuits at problem I could solve the
formula set problem we're given a
boolean formula and I can check whether
it's sort of the algae Rose function or
not faster then I would get that n X
doesn't have polynomial size formula
families where the int circuit is now
sort of a tree like formula
and in general for many circuit classes
see with clothes under reasonable
properties sort of clothes let's say the
clothes under oars and ands if I can
solve it faster than an exhaustive
search just by a little bit they don't
have shown that NX doesn't have pollen
size circuit families or each circuit is
drawn from this class C but in fact this
connection works even for this gap
version of the problem so if I solve it
faster just slightly faster than an
exhaustive search so recall this is
easily solved with Ramnath but I'm
trying to solve it at terminus tically
okay then
NX would be not in poly SCI C okay so so
for example if you just take generic
circuits okay it's widely believed that
this problem this gap C set problem is
solvable in polynomial time
deterministically okay if we can solve
it slightly faster than an exhaustive
search deterministically we would have
in X not in people all right okay and
and so it seems very reasonable say well
maybe we could actually show such an
algorithm exists by assuming that in X
biz and ppalli to begin with so if we
show it say in xnp poly imply such
algorithm then we would actually just
have unconditionally in x11 people
because in X and P poly applies the
algorithm implies in X nodded people
yeah
it's the artifact of the computation
while it's so like if you look at the
base of your computational model like
you might look at the so-called random
access machine where you get to jump to
any register and that you want in
constant time or you might look at a
model it's more like a Turing machine
where you have some tapes and you have
to sort of move back and forth in these
tapes it depends on the model so I just
pick tend to be sufficiently large so
that doesn't matter which of these
models you look at yeah yeah I had to
pick some constant I just want to
demonstrate the constants not that large
uniformity is non-uniformity right and
so the last problem is non uniformly
solvable that's true yeah yeah so it is
also non uniformly solvable so it's also
an NP poly
yeah yeah another thing is that if you
had non deterministic algorithms for
sort of proving circuit is unsatisfiable
with given the promise that it's either
inside it's 5 or at least half setteth
so I vote you would still get this in
exon I'm not quite sure how to use that
I do use it in certain arguments to say
something else but so even like
non-deterministic algorithm would work
so we know that for example a Sigma 2 P
our rooms are like it exists for all
time you know something slightly more MP
to the NP type algorithm obviously works
in poly-time by the sips argax Altman
theorem but yeah so the
non-deterministic algorithm would
actually suffice which model are we
talking about these multiple models here
yeah it doesn't yeah well the reason why
it works is because non-deterministic
exponential time is robust with respect
to the moment alright not NP is robust
because like there's these results of
Gurevich and shelah leaders had some
similar argument we're like even it you
can reduce like random access machines
to the multi tape turing machine setting
like very efficiently as long as you
have non intermón ism so certain proofs
of the KU clevon theorem using this so
that that's sort of why it's from
looking the deterministic setting maybe
not so so you can kind of leverage this
you multi-tape turing machine like below
that like one taper mechina probably I
mean so I was trying to say it doesn't
matter
so because non-deterministically these
things are equivalent up to poly log
factors yeah this is like sort of this
is like an advantage that we have so we
don't have to think about the model as
long as a reasonable one random access
machine so I just think Grand Am access
machine and that's you know word RAM
with word size order login or something
I don't know because I don't know what a
proof of that would look like because
they don't have to define what is an on
into mystic algorithm for me for SATA
it's easy right so have to say unset
right code nine determines to get and I
also have to say like what does it mean
to have a code on terms a gallon that is
like satisfying the promise but okay I
mean it can be defined well well-defined
and then you're saying reasonable to be
models disagree about the exact
deterministic time yeah actually we
don't know so much how much they
disagree deterministic the either that
because it's open whether
non-signatories he'll interesting time
but okay multi-tape but we don't know
but they could matter but they don't
hear this as a point
for these implications don't matter yeah
so this is a for all K there's a for all
quantifier in there yeah if you said for
a specific K I get this kind of thing it
would probably translate to a fixed
lower bound on here for like
non-deterministic to the end time so the
question was supposed like for a fixed K
like k equal to a thousand I managed to
solve this problem we didn't say
anything about this thing oh it would
certainly say something on e to the NP
for sure just slightly worse so in other
words like time to the end with an NP
Oracle just slightly more powerful than
this thing but we still don't know if it
has like linear size circuits so it
would be for a specific circuit size
relative to a thousand so probably if I
had you know 10 it would probably
preserve K yeah I mean we're probably
preserved okay like ie like into the
thousand divided by some sub polynomial
factor yeah yeah it would get some e to
the NP lower bound which is also open I
mean like xdmp in P poly is also open
like things like that yeah so there's
like a way which it concretely
translates for each K in fact
very necks is more complicated
okay so this is kind of a generic
diagram over rounds two lower bounds so
there are certain classes C for which
concrete lower bounds have improved
using this and this is the only known
way we have so far to prove such lower
bounds so so for like these things
called ACC and ACC of thresholds which I
will talk about later I mean it is a bit
weird the only way we know how to prove
such lower bounds to give some kind of
sour at least it's weird to me I feel
like this is some very generic thing
that is only maybe a guide to how you
might prove lower bounds but not
necessarily for each particular circuit
class is that the right way to do it
this way
see how much time to do
okay yeah for some reason it's things
that something else okay whatever okay
so so what I want to say is that as you
improve the circuit set algorithm more
and more you get stronger lower bounce
okay so this is something that was only
recently approved roughly a year ago
appeared stock this year so the
difference between this slide and the
previous one was that before I was
dividing by a polynomial factor okay and
I was only getting a circuit setup
however much work with polymer mini
gates okay so what it's saying here is
that if you divide by a sub exponential
factor so 2 to the into the epsilon for
some epsilon then you get strong a
stronger list of lower bound so instead
of going up to exponential time not
automatically you can get
quasi-polynomial time so into the PI log
in in time is not NP poly and similar
for boolean formulas and and so on so in
in general like I think of the left hand
side just relating back to the stuff
about pigs so the left hand side is like
things I expect to be true but should
not necessarily require enormous leap to
do especially the gap cset things and
the right-hand side is things I also
expect to be true but they look very
hard to prove without going through this
kind of thing like just sort of on their
own
and this connection was also used to
proof a new ACC lower bounds so it is
known that even not interested quasi
poly time can't support these so-called
ACC circuit families well all you need
to know about ACC right now is that it's
a subset of P poly and it's strongly
believed to be a proper subset of P poly
but it's a very strange subset of people
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so so you think
of epsilon it's just something ever so
slightly greater than zero yeah so think
I was like really tiny a very close yeah
yeah I mean like it he can't be like
whatever is supported by the machine
model right and our ability to analyze
the algorithm well so if it's two to the
end of the epsilon right then like
scaling as a function of n epsilon could
be like extremely extraordinarily tiny
but it might not affect the Machine
precision because because they're just
two to the end underneath its way that
it's like two main machine yeah I mean
it's just sort of whatever epsilon
satisfies the hypothesis if there is an
epsilon that satisfies this hypothesis
in the lower bound holds so I mean it it
could be I mean depending on your model
it won't be as small as the Machine
precision like in some models the
machine precision is actually a function
of the input length in a certain sense
in some of them all as we look at
depends on them all
yeah it's just really small like the
point zero zero one or something yeah
the point is this a hypothesis and I
mean yeah so when you get that thing for
some for any epsilon so it's easier to
prove it as epsilon gets smaller and
smaller yeah because I'm subtracting it
you know making the the circuit size
smaller and I'm subtracting from the
running time we're dividing by this to
the epsilon thing so I make I'm saying
the running time is larger this is easy
to get that lower bound yeah yeah yeah
that's roughly speaking where you sort
of pay for the epsilon us like in the
the degree of this polygon to some
function of 1 over Epsilon
and another thing that Kody meri and I
were able to to prove is that if you can
get set our rooms which sort of beat
exhaustive search in a very strong way
then we can even get lower bounds
against NP okay so if you have like
circuits at 1.9 at the end time on in
inputs in one point one of the in gates
then you have NP doesn't have into the
case sized circuits for all constant
okay now be careful this is not the same
as MP not NP poly okay there's a
difference so when I say NP naught and P
poly I'm saying that a fixed function
the sap problem for example doesn't have
any of the case size circuits for all
constants K when I say MP not in size in
the K for all K I'm saying you tell me
the K and then I will pick the function
in NP and it might run in in to the K to
the K to the K to the K time and but it
won't happen in the case sized circuits
so it's a different so this sort of
fixed polynomial size lower bound
questions are different thing yes yeah I
mean for like parity right doesn't have
pala sized units
you mean like if I put DNF there this
this thing no no it's like I'm getting
there yeah yeah this is this is this is
our in the realm of like maybe not true
yeah yeah yes oh this is going to be
explaining a little text boxes isn't
gonna pop up yeah but uh yes but if you
put outs well I thought you want to say
is if you put like a larger class here
like so if you put like P space here or
so called Sigma to piece and like that
then this things are just true and there
you see them in standard complexity
courses it's showing it for NP is a
major open problem so the point is I
getting these kinds of algorithms that
say you know improve by some tiny
exponential for exponential size things
would imply lower bounds against NP the
things that we're really after
implications from the slice wise if you
were to achieve and he's not in
scientific a is there any known
implications well I mean if it would
proofs it it implies some D
randomizations and things like this
because for example it's much stronger
than X not in P poly so so it implies
some interesting to your animations of
say Merlin Arthur
that's usually the kind of things we get
from over abouts there's a question
behind your back
yes oh that one yes miss my kids already
lost I always say that you wanna solve a
program on some exponential number of
gates so here I'm saying for some
epsilon and over there acid for all K so
so what's going on is that like for all
so what I needed you could think of it
as there exists a super polynomial
function on the previous slide and here
there exists a sub exponential function
roughly speaking there is a way to match
them
okay all right so so these kinds of
things so for circuits satin formulas
that these would refute the so-called
strong exponential time hypothesis in
fact much much stronger than that so
maybe not but this gap CSAT thing is
strongly believed to be true even so I
mean it's implied by so-called promise
or P and P sort of efficient hitting set
generators efficient pseudo-random so so
I wanted to say just on this slide that
even this connection has been used to
prove new lower bounds for say
representing boolean functions as linear
combinations or I call them sums of
things like linear thresholds ray lose
and low degree polynomials over a finite
field so I will talk about these in the
next lecture but I just want to
emphasize that even even this connection
has been used to to prove lower bounds
recently so I'll say a little bit about
some details and some progress and then
stop so I mean there results of the form
for example if you can solve safe on T
and e testing okay then you get either
in X naught MP Polly or you get the
permanent doesn't have Polly sized
algebraic circuits so this thing I view
as a tighter statement because this kind
of statement says actually any super
polynomial function it's so it
non-deterministic any super polynomial
function is not in P Polly
I mean like so I mean there might be
other results that I'm liking on but I
feel I feel like in terms of like this
this connection it's it's tighter than
the other stuff that has been shown
along those lines obviously Pawlenty any
testing is not the same problem as this
though so
positive some of the original so it's
just a sort of a real-valued some so
it's it's like so some of and would be
like the normal representation over the
reals of a polynomial over zero one
basis some of XOR would be the the over
the Fuu a basis any real numbers so
positive negative it just says that you
couldn't even use negative numbers so
it's a lower bound right it just says
you can't even use any real valued
combination of thresholds so there so
you tell me like into the hundred sighs
and then I will say here's a function MP
they came out beer is represented by any
real value linear combination of into
the hundred linear thresholds some
circles this is depth to neural nets
with sign activation
okay I am almost ready to take a break
so I'll just say this slide and then
take a break so this thing I've been
talking about a CC more formally so it's
problem solving with circuit families of
Paulo no size so up to the year it's
exactly ppalli but they have constant
depth so the gates have unbounded fan
they can take any number of inputs there
an and or and so called mod M gates for
some funny so any constant M will do so
even M equals six is interesting so what
is a mod six gate do it takes some
number of boolean inputs and it outputs
one if and only if that sum is divisible
by M that's what a mod M gate does so
it's just some primitive counting but up
to some modulo some constant and it's
only constant depth so if you think of
the depth is like three so there's sort
of three layers they've got these mod
six sums going on with ands and ORS this
is already a very interesting class and
the only kind of things we know are just
things through set algorithms so it's
clear that ACC is in P poly this is a
poly size but with all these other
restrictions it's probably a proper
subset so I think of ACC as an annoying
circuit class to prove lower bounds for
as low as I believe but first by
barrington in 1986 it's the 0 such class
so it actually means alternating
circuits with counting but I don't know
I've been looking at it for a long time
I guess so so the kind of may like the
first lower bound that was proves via
these set algorithms was that not whose
exponential time doesn't have ACC
circuits of this kind and so it was like
the first guy I guess of interesting
lower bound against like arbitrary
pollen size ACC and very recently with
Kody meri we got this down the Kazi
polynomial even for things like AZ sea
of thresholds so this is annoying
circuits with linear threshold gates
at the bottom below them like right
right at the inputs so oh I think I'll
take a break here oh sorry
think of a linear threshold gate is
something that we're taking some boolean
inputs and it's computing some linear
form so so over some real valued
constants and it's checking whether that
is at least a certain threshold T which
is also a real value and you know if yes
it outputs one if no way output zero the
inputs are boolean yeah exactly
yeah arbitrary rules from analyzing all
constant data circuits of all finite
gates all the finite gates you mean like
like Oh like boolean functions oh I mean
well so all boolean functions if you got
unbounded fan and you can solve
everything with one gate I mean you
could have something like symmetric
boolean functions because these are all
symmetric boolean functions that more or
less captures TC 0
[Applause]